some of the coolest examples of the use
of crowdsourcing in places you would not
expect come from nasa the space agency
in the u.s has used open innovation and
crowdsourcing systematically for the
past decade
they have learned to use open innovation
to solve problems in the space station
to help think about how to keep
astronauts safe and healthy while
they're in space and even how to deal
with space poo so nasa has thought a lot
about how to incorporate open innovation
into their processes
another cool example comes from the
defense department in the u.s where they
actually started
challenges to help create the autonomous
driving revolution that all of us will
be seeing over the next few decades they
started challenges and and and contests
to enable anybody from around the us to
participate and create solutions to
creating software and robots that could
allow cars to travel on their own
so in key key areas space exploration
for humanity autonomous driving
open innovation has played an important
role in
unlocking innovation from around the
world
[Music]